[Music]
back here at home the la bonita
supermarket that partially collapsed on
friday as starting off the week closed
it was red tagged by the county deemed
unsafe in order to stay closed the store
is on desert inn and eastern the
incident hurt four people and today
workers are reporting to a new location
bianca holman is live this afternoon
with how this is impacting people in the
area bianca
you know this parking lot is typically
busy with morning shoppers getting their
groceries or breakfast or you know
breakfast smoothies from this deli here
but now it's all quiet and you can see
there's yellow tape and a fence that
surrounds the front of this labunita
supermarket it was a very intense scene
on friday morning the fire department
sent six engines two trucks two rescues
and two battalion chiefs
a heavy rescue company and air unit also
responded now about 150 people work in
the 3 36 000 square foot building about
50 to 60 people were inside at the time
of the collapse the four people who were
injured were taken to nearby hospitals
with minor injuries and employees from
this store were reassigned to other
labor need to locations shoppers who
frequent this area often were shocked
and puzzled to see this damage
facebook actually is when i seen it and
as soon as i seen it i was like yeah i
know that place
so it was it was surprising though i'm
just curious of what caused it
like buildings don't just fall down
so the cause of this collapse is under
investigation we reached out to la
bonita for an additional update they
told us once the cause is determined it
will be shared now during this morning
we've seen quite a bit of foot traffic
from
the engineers contractors other people
and other authorities coming in and
taking a couple of pictures and
monitoring this area here so again once
we have an update we will keep you
updated online and on air reporting from
desert inn in eastern bianca holmen 8
news now